I'm a stay at home wife
and I get asked all the time,
what does your husband do for you?
And I just felt so loved tonight that I had to share.
I am in a production of beauty and the Beast
with my local community theater,
and I have a three hour rehearsal
that I have to drive to town.
To town is only 30 minutes away.
But I've already been in town today.
My car is in the shop,
so it won't be my car,
it's my husband's truck.
And I just did not feel like driving into town
to go to that rehearsal.
But I have to go to rehearsal
and I asked my husband, hey,
would you mind to drive me into town?
And my husband does not normally drive me into town.
It's a three hour rehearsal,
but he said yes.
And I just feel so loved
that he would carve out that evening
to drive me to my rehearsal.
He's not even spending time with me
except for the car ride there and back.
But he's gonna stay in town,
do a couple errands, and I.
I just feel so loved.
And for anyone who says
that's the bare minimum,
my husband does so many things for me.
He's had a long day at work today.
There's no reason why he should drive me into town
except for the fact that he loves me. Anyway,
I just wanted to share that
because I love My husband and
I just wanted to give him a little shout out tonight.